hi everybody welcome to the future
academy channel today we're going to be
talking about
typography it's one of my most favorite
things to talk about because it's the
foundation of all
good graphic design and joining me today
live are my two cohorts
mark contreras and jonah who are calling
in remotely managing this hey mark
what's up
hello what's got vanessa everybody
welcome to the future academy channel
today we're going to be talking about
typography it's one of my most favorite
things to talk about sorry about that
guys did you guys hear that
i heard it no okay that sucked let me
close that window i want to chat with
people but i'm not going to do it now
turning off everything okay all right so
uh jonah
how's it going holding down the ford at
the office here and just in case you
guys are wondering what the heck's going
on everybody has been allowed to work
from home and courage do so some people
feel like the office is a better place
to be and safer place to be than their
apartment with their friends
um so that's what's happening joan is in
the conference room jonah
sure am looking a little dark
yes sir me and all my friends over here
you have your one fan my one fan
number one fan okay we're joined today
by
a whole bunch of people can we get a
group shot here yeah there you go
there we are everybody just wave and say
hello
yay all right we see a lot of familiar
faces people have been on the channel
before
and we're gonna get going so we're gonna
jump into the typography critique
and today i'll be using adobe
illustrator and hopefully i'll be using
it correctly we'll see
and you guys are all very smart so if
you see something i'm doing
that isn't right you guys let me know
now in case you were wondering what the
heck this is and how you get
how you participate in part of this
essentially everybody who's purchased
this course
and who's interested in submitting their
work uh there's the topography one
course here and
like all our products during this tough
time everything has been discounted so
if you guys
enroll in the class you could submit
your work we're going to try this thing
out
our plan is to do this for seven weeks
but if it doesn't work out that way
well we tried and we know that there's a
lot of people out there
who are stuck at home obviously for for
very good reasons
and want to learn and so we're trying to
set the bar to kind of
show how other teachers or or
collaborators can work together can have
a conversation remotely safely
and it could be just as good as the real
thing now before we get started i want
to talk to everybody about
how to do this on your own obviously
there are a lot of people who haven't
taken our course who
want to get better at designing
typography so i put together
a five-point self-critique checklist for
you
okay and it's part of the course but
just to quickly go over it
when you're doing your design work
especially when it comes to type
you want to pick one focal point you're
going to hear me talk about this over
and over again
what am i supposed to look at you as the
designer you're supposed to control that
experience for the
reader and say hey this is important and
you can see that it's subjective because
each designer can pick something that
they think is more important than
something else
and i'm okay with that but we need to
make a decision pick one thing
so every time we come upon a layout and
you see too many things that we're
looking at
you're going to start to think oh we
have to reduce this and we we can
there's a lot of design techniques that
you can that you can use
to help draw the eye towards one thing
next is you want to think about order
what am i supposed to read first second
and third the primary secondary and
tertiary read
as many people have referred to this in
the designer art world
so think about the order and how it
flows now at least in the united states
in america we read from the top
left corner we read from left to right
top to bottom
just remember that left to right top to
bottom
and i'm sure there's going to be a bunch
of layouts where it's going to be a
little confusing because i don't know
what to read next
now if you follow all the rules and all
the rules we've laid out
you're going to create something that
feels really solid but it's going to
lack
a little something extra that element of
surprise the unexpected
so typography is about repetition and
contrast so repetition is the order
contrast is the element of surprise in
in the world of cooking it might be
you're eating something that's like a
soup but then there's a little bit of
a crunchy thing like deep fried onions
that are thrown on top
that's a little element of surprise so
the soup is wonderful
but that little crunch has good mouth
feel that's what we're looking for
in the designs number four is negative
space that
a lot of designs tend to crowd
everything on the page and give us no
room to breathe
and i'm going to show you one very
simple super
like after i showed you you're like why
didn't i do that well this is what this
is about it's a learning
opportunity for all of us just make sure
you have some negative space to let your
design breathe
and the last thing that you do is you
check for the details
were there any typos did everything line
up correctly is something off by two or
three pixels
so we do this in this order one through
five we don't start with the details
because overall
if we don't have a strong focal point if
there isn't a clear read
if they're not elements of surprise and
enough breathing space the details at
that point don't matter
we work in this way all right now i'm
going to jump around
and i'm going to pick somebody who we're
supposed to go with first um
tom francisconi tom okay so here's tom's
work here
so this is tom hopefully i spelt your
name right tom so is
tom's online with us right now we've
asked everybody to submit three layouts
now theoretically for your homework
you're supposed to do 10
and you picked your best three so let's
get right into it
okay and i'm navigating
um using the keyboard shortcuts and if i
move too quickly somebody just let me
know what's going on
so the first thing i want to do is look
at the layout
and you're going to get an impression
like does this feel right does it feel
like it it can breathe is there a focal
point all that kind of stuff so
looking at this layout here it's clearly
that he's pulled out
design and i see that right there let me
pull up my layers palette here
okay so there's a lot extra going on
here
okay we'll lock the foreground element
here so he's pulled that design so
that's very clear that he wants us to
look at this and we're going to read
from top to bottom left to right so this
is the next thing that we're looking at
right here
is the journal for graphic design
i think this is an overall very clean
layout it's very easy to
uh to read and to look at and i think by
orienting
everything on a 90 degree angle like
this here
he's further separating why can i select
this there we go
he's further separating this group from
this group i like it
and if some of you guys don't know what
we're doing today they were all given
a set of words to work with you must use
all of it you can use more of it meaning
you could duplicate it but you can't use
less than that
you can't just arbitrarily delete
information and
we're allowed to use helvetica and we're
only allowed to use one point size and
one weight
so let's look at what point size this is
is eight point type okay all right and
he's using
covetica new neue regular all right
i think that's pretty cool very
successful layout tom
there's not much i would change on this
i think it's really nice there's one
little thing that
bothers me just a little bit i'm not
sure if i can improve it but let's try
and a lot of design and especially while
we're learning is to try something and
if we do something that
doesn't work we just hit undo so what
i'd like to do is move it down a little
bit and see
if this helps it or not and what i'm
bothered by is this i'm going to draw a
little box here
and again the objective here is so that
you can learn to break down things and
see
yeah so right now you can see that the
margins between
the vertical and the horizontal are a
little bit different we can make them
the same or not but what i'm going to do
is i'm going to show you something okay
i'm going to take this sorry this entire
grouping here
i'm going to try to move it up and take
a look at it
and i'm going to also move it down so
through the extremities we start to
learn what works and what doesn't work
okay so i want you to try that and you
could also try pushing it
over to the right as well to see if that
improves your layout
does increasing the amount of let me get
my brush here
where are my brushes i had this all set
up
okay so i'm going to get my brushes oh
that was a different one okay
that's right this is my composite file
if we increase
this space here
and decrease this space here we can
create more interesting
and dynamic contrast between the two
what you what you want to try to
generally avoid
is things being even so if i take
this and move it back here you'll start
to see that
proportionately the amount of space here
is going to be similar to the amount of
space here
and you may not recognize this kind of
in your eye but you feel it
as you look at the design so that's what
i want to do i want to push things
around and see if i can improve it
this is a very good layout tom i think
you did a great job
this is i'm just walking you through
things that you can try on your own
okay to push things around
okay these two layouts are a little less
successful for me
and there's a couple things i want you
to try here because i see that you're
using
this grouping here did you increase it
let's say one two three four
yeah you did okay now in this one
it's a little harder for me to figure
out what you want me to look at and
before i told you guys about your
the tools that you can use despite us
being limited to one point size and one
weight
there's still a lot that we can use
through spacing and repetition
and i'll tell you what i mean first i'm
going to hide this okay
i'll hide that which is command three if
we took this and we brought it closer
proximity communicates like
grouping like these things belong
together right
but if i were to take this and move it
farther away you're going to start to
see like
they're still grouped in a way that they
align to this access
right here they line here
right i have to not sure i don't want to
do that
okay they align here but by pushing it
farther away i make it so that you can't
ignore this one
element so now this becomes the clear
focal point that's
read number one this would be the second
read and then this down here would be
the third read
we have to still contend with um
with this group so the problem i have
with this layout
let me undo everything here the problem
i have with this layout right now is
that
these things don't seem to be connected
to this at all it's almost like two
families like there's
the family the johnsons over here and
then the smiths over here
and in design you want to try to bring
these things together
well how can you do that well you can
try by bringing
some of this on the same axis over here
like pretend that that lined up there
that makes a different kind of layout a
different feeling there's other things
that you can do perhaps you could try
pulling this over to the right
and getting this to line up but you want
to you want to have some kind of
relationship between these things
otherwise they feel
they're in completely different
universes okay
and the last one here
oh you know what you may have the old
assignment here
tom because the new assignment is is
resonate right
so we we we modified the assignment just
a little bit so in case you're doing
this and you're going to participate
with us every single week
do your best to use the new type okay
it's it's designed to help
make the type setting easier for you
originally i gave this assignment to use
this exact amount of copy
but i found that people were struggling
with it so i made it a little bit easier
so take a look at that okay overall nice
job tom
i'm going to close this file here all
right do we have somebody else that we
have to talk about next
nope whoever you want to select next oh
my computer's freaking out now
it just was waking up all right so let
me try
this person here okay this is uh in a
riddick i'm sorry if i butchered that i
know i butchered it
and these are the three things that you
submitted i can already tell right now
you should use a template that we
provided to you because everybody did
their files look like this it is
important for you to look at it like
this versus the way that you did it okay
oops now i'm going the wrong direction
ah
i've lost it sorry guys is it this one
yeah or we're back here i wanted to
really focus on this layout in
particular here
i think there's some really interesting
things going on now
i'm pulling out layouts not because
they're good or they're bad but because
there's something for me to talk about
so just because i pick on your work it
doesn't mean that i hate it or i love it
it's just a learning opportunity for all
of us okay what i like about this layout
there's some problems here uh is that
you're using a much bigger point size
and you're also using the
oblique oblique weight here i believe
yeah helvetica new neue bold italic okay
um it's actually oblique not
italic but that's kind of interesting
okay anyways
it's okay for things to cut off the
edges the way you've done
and i want to encourage everybody that's
designing to
to respect the edges but then also push
beyond that what i don't like about this
layout is
there's some strange oh i know what it
is you see the letter spacing here you
have some big
letter spacing and then you have some
smaller one it's because the type has
been
forced justified instead of
just left justified so when you force
justify it
it expands all the type to fit the edges
okay
and we want to generally avoid that
because it creates these things called
rivers
so what you're seeing here let me get my
brush pen out here you're seeing bigger
gaps
and then you're seeing smaller gaps and
it's kind of arbitrary what's happening
here
and you as the topographer you want to
control that i don't know why but our
eye tends to focus
not only on the the material you put on
on the page but also the negative space
the shapes that are created
in between like these shapes here you
just need to pay attention to that
so i think in general without a doubt if
you're just getting started design and
you want to improve your
justify everything left just do it it
works better it's easier to read and
it's more pleasing to the eye
so i would start doing that now you
you're losing the cut off the edge part
which is totally fine because all you
have to do is then take this type
and cut some of it off and it's implied
that there's more there
okay there's other things that you can
do now this is revealing a problem
of why of you not using our template is
because now you're
you're seeing the edges bleed beyond
here and it's creating a different
feeling than it would have if it's cut
off and i'll show you what i mean
if i take this layout which i'm going to
i'm going to copy this and go to my
composite file
okay i'm going to grab one of my
templates here let me just drag it down
this is not going to be perfect because
my artboard
i can change power board
okay i'm going to delete this part and
i'm going to lock
i'm not going to do it now
okay there's your type center for layer
so you see what happens now is we have a
lot more freedom
to move your layers around
your type around and it it's going to be
masked off
so please if you're taking the course
there's already a template just use it i
don't know why you wouldn't
it doesn't make a lot of sense to me
okay so let's see what we can do to
to make this layout a little bit more
pleasing the problem with the layout as
it stands right now is there's a lot of
stuff happening
all over the page and what we want to do
is pick one focal point like what's the
most important
thing to you right now and it's hard to
tell
it's like there's this is resonate the
title the mask head for the magazine
and then there's the sub head or the i
forget what that's called
and then there's all this information
it's really hard so
it's really hard for us to distinguish
what is important what is not
oof let me get this back to normal here
there will be a time and place for you
guys to really experiment with type and
push
the boundaries i think in the later
stages once you have
a better handle on how to use type
that's the time for that
so we have all kinds of weird spacing in
here
give me a second while i work on that
and mark if somebody has a question just
let me know okay
yep yeah
i see why you did that okay and
again justify left
and hopefully when when i've finished
this part
now if you have resonate here and you
pull it out just by a little bit
that's all you need to do to make this
thing stand out and pop okay
you can you can group this with this if
you wish or you can bring it down
and make it grouped with this
so if you keep working on this this
should start to look like something
here's another tip i want to share with
you guys you see right here january
february 2018
that information is kind of hard to work
with right now but if you were just to
change this
to numerals or something else it'll be a
lot easier for you to work with
and it'll look different so something
about numbers i just love the way
numbers
and other characters look besides the
alphabet it just brings
a different visual element to the to the
page now
again if you wanted to you could do an
underscore here
you can do an m dash oops that's not an
m
you can do a colon there's a lot of
different things you can do to try to
break this information up
you can space this out
you can even bring this to the top shoot
and then move this down
so some things for you to play around
with and think about okay so my key
takeaway for you right now
so make sure you use the template move
away from force justifying the type
because you
you're losing control over the spacing
you're creating a lot of rivers
and then to really try to find
one focal point what is that thing
that's going to make this thing
interesting
and then design everything else around
that
all right chris we have a quick question
go ahead
so kyle daley is asking is there ever a
point
to using the paragraph to force justify
oh good question okay there is and it
usually happens
around newspapers like newspapers and
some magazines like to force justify i
don't know why they do and they like to
have that
and you have to spend a lot of time
working the words and doing paragraph
breaks so that
they look good a lot of times writers
can
can do this and then they'll change the
way that they write the words but if
you're
given words from somebody else obviously
you need to respect
the the text you were given and you're
not really
you're not supposed to change the text
if it's if it's a
it's some writer's work it's like
somebody else changing your design
so i find that it's very rare that
there's a reason to force justify your
attacks except for when i see it in
newspapers
it's a standard they do it you don't
have to do it
i guess for them it looks a little
neater when all their columns line up
okay thanks for that question so we're
going to move on to ronan buckley right
now
uh let's take a look at ronan's work is
running buckley on
okay there's a bunch of things going on
here so
so ronan first thing i notice on this
layout here is
you're pushing all of your design
elements
to the edges okay i'll talk about why
you
generally just don't want to do that
now an analogy i've used before and if
you're a fan of the show you've heard me
say things like this
imagine this as the layout of a room
like the floor plan
and you're looking at it very rarely
would you ever design a room
and take all the furniture and push it
all the way to the edges like the bed
the bookshelf uh the nightstand all
these things and that's how it kind of
feels it's like we're just pushing
everything to the edge and we're not
utilizing the entire space okay
so we're gonna look at more layouts this
is not one of your more successful
layouts and there's a lot of things that
you're doing here
you're you're putting some names in the
darker or more transparent gray
which you're allowed to use right
different tints and shades and
transparency
totally legitimate but i think it's the
idea that you're pushing everything to
the edge
if there's nothing else on this page and
i'm going to try to do this right now
like that would look really handsome
just resonate
january february 2018 i oh shoot
these things really should should be
like one group and not
three things because it makes it hard
for us to adjust
the leading i would have just moved the
lighting in a little
tighter but then i'm kind of doing
manually which is not the way you want
to do this
okay like that would look really good
now we have a different problem it's
like we have to design the rest of the
page
but taking all these things pushing an
edge not a big fan of that you're not
utilizing the entire
space that were given probably of the
three layouts that you submitted i i
think this is your most successful one
here
just taking a minute to look at it here
journal for graphic
design okay i like this this is quite
successful
so this group of information
all oops how come i can't draw a
straight line anyways
this group of information lines up on
one access and it's good it's strong
you pull that resonate above it all and
you've broken it
into different groups right so features
i don't know why there's features twice
here
you probably don't need that
okay and then there's this whoa
holy cow okay so this was individually
placed here okay
a little bit of work there so journal
for graphic design this becomes almost
like an illustration a grid a dot
pattern and i like it because it breaks
up this
you can almost say like this is
obviously a group this is the second
group that you would probably see and
this is the third group depending on how
you're seeing it
but because you've kept everything
relatively small
you've created a lot of white space or
negative space for yourself around these
areas
and so that your eye has opportunity to
move around
if you use a larger point size it would
be much more difficult to do a layout
like this so
you're going to see in some layouts all
i'm going to do is make the point size
smaller and you're going to see
the feeling of how you perceive it is
improved okay
so this is probably your best layout i
like this treatment um
probably a little bit more we can do
here in terms of
figuring out the files built in a
strange way here
let me group this so i wonder if
bringing it closer to this
or farther away would make it more or
less interesting
and seeing if we can get this to like
three groups instead of one two three
four five
okay okay good job
so don't save back to this here
okay this is uh bertram christopherson
is that right bertram yeah
i like this i like that you're trying
different ways to
deal with a masthead from breaking up
like this
resin eight and writing it all the way
out and then resonate with the divider
line
and then resonate with like a bullet
point in between i encourage everybody
that's working on this
to go ahead and explore different ways
of treating the mass head
because we can deconstruct and
reconstruct it in different ways which
will give us some options
okay a couple things i see here um
aside from you doing the math head
differently
i'm noticing that you're using the same
elements a little bit too much
like for example this is literally that
but just with less spacing right when i
put them next to each other
and we can try to do it in more
different ways
and it'll the more you explore the more
you try the more you fail the more
you're going to learn in this whole
process okay
so i'm going to encourage you to try to
to break
up your groups a little bit differently
so that there's more ways of
interpreting this information
oh this has been outlined already huh
yeah let me look at this
okay uh in the future i'm gonna suggest
that you don't outline your type
and unless you're using some exotic cut
of helvetica that
very few people are gonna have i have a
helvetica i have helvetica neuaya and i
also have
helvetica now and so if you're using um
new house grotesque or some other
version of helvetica i'm not gonna have
it
but i can't work on your file
unfortunately
okay there's no way for me to break this
information up differently
one thing i would suggest that you try
and we've seen other people do it
successfully
is to take this this list and make it a
paragraph
just to see what options that opens up
for you
another thing i'm going to ask you to
try explore is to
take this and make it bigger
like a like a bigger point size just so
you get the feel for like how to deal
with
the information and we can learn a lot
from that and i want you to try it in a
different way
so those of you guys that are trying
this layout at home i'll show you what i
mean
res then nate let's say we do that right
character helvetica i'm going to use
helvetica
now display
and i'm going to use the light or thin
weight so if you buy
the complete font family from
monotype on helvetica now you'll notice
that
i have so many different weights can you
guys see that look
it's doing a little dance on the screen
shimming towards us
and that opens up a lot of options can
you lower that down chris
i think it's being covered by your
pop-up
i don't know what we're talking about
say again jonah can you lower down that
uh font box thing yeah character box
yeah yeah okay most afternoon let me put
the paragraph controls in here too
okay yeah so if you guys see if i
highlight this
you can see like i have a lot of
different weights to work with all the
way from hairline to extra black
so the point of all this was to
encourage you to try
different weights like don't just use
eight point type helvetica regular
uh try something in bold try something
[Music]
even extra bold or black that's extra
black
and you're going to start to get a feel
for how to use the different weights
and you're going to learn so much more
okay i just want you to encourage that
because as i look at this
it looks like you're using helvetica
just regular weight the entire time
and they're all almost all the same
point size so you're gonna you're not
gonna
experience as much in terms of exploring
the different
point sizes and weights okay now you're
only allowed to use one point size and
one weight
per layout but not for your entire set
so maybe that wasn't clear
all right i can't work on this file too
much
because it's already all outlined and i
don't want to go through and move each
character
by hand so let me close that file don't
say
and just to fill people in if they're
just joining so what we're doing here is
we're going through an exercise from our
typography 01 class
and they're given a specific set of
texts and the goal here is to
learn how to break down text and see
based on priority and hierarchy so chris
is going through the exercises from the
students
in the class yes thanks mark all right
this is from i don't know how to say
this is that mls or emily
ostakas and we're gonna just look at our
layout
right now or
i don't know if it's a man or woman so
sorry if i messed that part up
i see so very similar things here
everybody's using just that one
let me lock the foreground mascara
okay and this is 12 point type
okay i'm going to suggest that you all
try to do something
it's strange but the way that computers
are set up the default
font and the point size is terrible
usually it's terrible
and the default typeface is usually
something like myriad
if you're on the mac and it's 12 point
type i don't know why it's like the
worst point size to work with or maybe
because we see it so much that it just
becomes really boring to us
so in this case i'm going to take this
let me uh
let me duplicate this
before i do that all right we'll put it
to the side for now
take this and i'm going to change the
point size i'm going to change it to
eight point and you'll notice now
without changing the layout at all by
just changing the point size to eight
point
we create so much more space for our eye
to move around and i don't know about
you but for me
the layout feels like it's easier to
breathe just because there's more
negative space
and so that's why i want to encourage
you to try that
conversely if i take this and i try to
make it like 14 or 16 point type
it creates a different feeling it feels
more like a poster or something else it
feels less precious
and you want to just push this around
okay so i'm just all i'm doing is
changing point size there
this is a pretty good layout by my
judgment here and the reason why i like
it is because
it's not trying to do too much when you
when you're when you have a lot of
constraints like one point size one
weight
there's really not that much you can do
so don't go and try to make
some crazy things in there okay uh
there's good
hierarchy and alignment here that
resonate is connected to the
to the descriptor there so it's resonate
and the journal for graphic design that
makes a lot of sense those are grouped
horizontally like that and then the rest
of the information is grouped on a
vertical axis
we probably need to play around with
spacing like let me try if i bring this
down
i'm just eyeballing this here we
probably should be working with some
kind of grid
and i want to shift it because the other
thing you want to try to do is avoid
these middle spots like i said before
you see this proportion or that amount
of space
it's not that different than this amount
of space so i want to push and pull so
if i were able to take this
and push it here that becomes more
interesting layout or
the opposite way which is to try to push
it here
so when you guys have a grid try to go
not in the middle
okay so if i take this i know i'm just
trying to go on one side
maybe that's more interesting i don't
know or i go the other way
and you may find that the spacing
between the resonate and the rest of
this this column of text
might be too far away so you bring it in
closer and that gives you a lot more
options now
okay some things to think about there
yeah so what i'm seeing here and i want
to encourage you guys for the next pass
at this
is to try to break up your text in
different ways
when i look at these two they're almost
the exact same layout except for
they're done with justified right type
instead of justified left type
or flush left flush right right so
if you see in this issue it's it's
exactly the same
breakup almost and then the features
here it's just flipped
that's all it is so i want you to try to
explore
make some ugly layouts try to do the
weirdest thing
and then figure out why doesn't it work
and then fix that and then you're going
to discover a lot more okay
closing this file
okay this is yoonji uh who's who
reminded me she's been on the show
before so i'm glad to see her work here
there's some pretty cool things
happening here so i i think i know how
to make this layout
a little bit better uh this confuses me
a little bit
uh because resonate is facing this way
and the h should be connected to this
and i would appreciate it if this were
just flipped around
so if i double click on this and type in
180 degrees
it should be facing the right way at
this point
there's really no reason why you would
make this upside down in my opinion
because they're connected okay you
dropped the baseline and i think that's
fine
and so you're going to start to see some
layouts now where people are taking
uh what is normally a layout like this
and then they're rotating it and
sometimes rotating off axis like that
gives a little kind of dynamic energy it
feels
unsettled off kilter so you want to make
sure the layout works first
before you rotate it that you kind of
understand the principles of design
because it just makes a little harder to
work with um
because you have less space to work with
okay but i think in terms of
the layouts that you submitted this is
your most interesting layout
and i think once we start to open up the
parameters you'll you'll have a lot more
uh options to work with for example you
could have taken this
in the in the next in the coming weeks
where you can make it a lot bigger and
it creates a lot more
uh visual interest than you have right
now
so let's try this again let's take this
it is also 12 points
let's try 10 point
and how it opens up the space and you're
using bold here
let's try light and see what happens oh
i can't seem to switch it
okay what is going on
i see yunji you also have helvetica now
it seems like that's cool do you have
the entire family
i think so you do wow
so i'll send you the link for
of course wow okay that's very cool no
no i didn't
i found it that's why that's what i
meant i'll send you the link
no don't send me any illegal links
yeah we're friends with people type i'm
just saying hey you're gonna pretend
like this was not said but
all right but you should try different
weights right so text weight
and and display weight etc and to then
look at light bulb and regular
because just by changing that you're
going to get a whole different feel
right so don't stick to just one point
size one weight
per layout you have to stay to that but
in in your exploration you could try a
lot of different point sizes
so let me see here in the journal for
graphic design okay
uh yunji is doing something interesting
here too she's using all caps
to separate this information from this
which is upper lowercase or title case
uh depending how you look at that right
lester peel did you spell lester beale
right
is that how you spell less reveal let's
look at king let me just verify
something it is okay
dodged a bullet there all right so
um i like the way that you've broken
uh shoot see once you start putting
something on an
on an angle like this it's really hard
to keep things aligned so like like i
was saying before
design it vertically and horizontally
get it right and then as your last
little thing
try to rotate it because once you do
that it just makes it really hard to
work with
there's some things here that you can
really push this is the one time where i
think hey
what if you were to push this right to
the edge
because this will glue it together so it
should be on the same baseline which i'm
having a hard time lining up perfectly
right and i'll show you what i mean let
me try just use this
draw a line
this is my baseline here so i can
connect this okay
you should have this like right around
here
that way your eye can complete that your
eye will take us across there
and there's other things you can do that
might be event like might be kind of
interesting for you to play with
right so they still follow the same
axis this grid you know
what the heck did i just do
okay because it's i don't know it's not
lined up
here we go so guys i'm i'm winging this
right now
i don't want to go through like the
process of making sure those things line
up
and now you might say wow i'm breaking
that connection between resin and eight
that's where you can go back and type
this in as eigh ht
if that helps to create a stronger
baseline to draw your eye across okay
but i think that's probably like you can
push that and try
moving that up there and maybe taking
this and moving a little closer to this
i'm not sure
i'm trying to also avoid the splitting
the composition in half because if you
look at this
it is almost literally like in half here
if i take this
and draw it like that you see you want
to try to push it
either to the thirds like the one third
rule where
and i'll show you what i mean we can
take all this now
avoid this line and just move it
there and let me see if i delete this
what happens
so you try to go that way and you could
try to go the other way and see what
what you get
okay uh let's see here
these are pretty standard okay
now i'm going to take a break from
looking at the three layouts and i'm
going to switch gears here
i want to remind everybody that's tuning
in right now if you're interested in
learning more about typography
and you need a crit of your own this is
a five-step process that you guys can
follow
to be able to critique your own work is
to choose a focal point choose one thing
that's really important to you
it doesn't have to be the same thing
every single layout try something
different
think about the order and usually we
talk about groups of three
and then having a primary a secondary
and tertiary read
to introduce one element of surprise you
shouldn't see with yunji choose like
pushing type and
throwing things off access and having a
little bit of fun with that i
strongly encourage you to do that uh
just reducing the point size and
and playing around with the different
weights of the fonts that you're using
can create a lot more negative space or
reduce negative space but in a very
intentional way
and then finally we get into the details
since this is the first week that we're
critiquing this work
we are not focusing too much on the
details because i think
there are some bigger broader problems
that we're trying to resolve let me jump
in here
i've i went through all the submissions
and i
copy and pasted some of the layouts here
for us just to talk about okay
now i'm going to talk about this one
right here this is from lars pal
and very nice layout you can see that
it's off access or not off access i'm
sorry
it's pushing away from the center center
line which is right here
and and lars is using these black lines
in here
which makes the layout look really good
the only problem is
we're not allowed to use lines right now
so lars's instincts are like this needs
something i want you to create visual
interests without adding additional
elements
at this stage so this one is like one of
those strikes right where
a good layout but not following the
rules and for right now you need to stay
within the constraints that you were
provided
and also here we see another layout this
is from christina tastana and she's on
on the live call with us because i saw
her earlier very similar to what yunji
was doing
and tilting it off access creating very
simple grouping here
and it's very strong layout and i i can
tell
that she knows how to use compositional
elements so
she felt something was off so you know
how with yunji's layout which i've
closed already
we put one of the letters up here and
then she rotated the type
i could do it here just rotate it
maybe i could do it more scientifically
and rotate it like this
90 degrees boom okay so
oh i see so you you kind of cheated
christina but you
you worked within the parameters this is
kind of interesting we'll talk about
this in a second
so with yunji's layout she had something
like this right and then she
separated she divorced like one letter
from their s and that is very similar to
what christine is doing but just
using type so when when you understand
how to manipulate the type you can
create
the same feeling as these lines that
christina is using
just with type and perhaps lars can
figure out the same thing
and that's why having these constraints
are really good at pushing
your exploration and trying a lot of
different things okay
now i was going to strike you with a
foul here with adding these elements but
you just added
dashes or minus signs so i think you're
still kind of you're still good within
the parameters what we're doing
i love that you're kind of found a legal
way to cheat a little bit by adding
lines
and i'm going to say for next week let's
not do that okay
i think this is totally fine it's
actually a really nice layout
i like these elements that you've added
because it creates visual interest it
it pulls my eye across the screen across
the page
and that's usually something that you
want so
she didn't feel compelled to fill the
entire page but by adding
this line and this line she activates
the rest of the page and i think that's
really cool
and she also added this separator
for the journal for graphic design so
you can see these dashed lines help to
say
this is a different piece of information
than the rest of this even though it's
the same point size and the same weight
on the same grid point so nicely done
there christina
okay let me jump around here here's
another one i want to look at
okay this is from james flynn i think
james is in here as well but i'm not
sure
so james uh you're also using the older
typeset so
i apologize if you've taken the course
before and you're submitting war to be
critiqued that's totally fine
but since then we've updated the course
and if you haven't looked at it recently
you'll want to re-watch it because we
added more critique videos and more tips
on how to build stronger layouts as
you're getting started okay
i saw an opportunity here to to design
something so
i'm going to lock this good it's locked
all right is it
what is that okay anyways
the layer's been locked so we could
design it okay
we have clearly three groups we have
hierarchy
we have one we have two and we have
three
and like i said before i'm going to read
from top to bottom left to right so my
scan
my scans across the top and i move
bottom
and then i get to this point here okay
that makes sense
the problem i have with this layout is
there's not a lot of relationship
between these three things james
and i want to try to find a way to make
them tied together
and you can the easiest and the
strongest way to do this is to find a
grid point like a grid line like that
and get some of the things to line up
and another way is to get things to line
up on that
good point okay and if you guys are
using
grids this is what the grids are for
they help to keep things ordered
if you take a bunch of things and you
drop them on the floor they feel chaotic
they feel messy
and it doesn't look pleasing to the eye
the
the instance the instant you put them in
a box of
like a gridded box then all of a sudden
all that chaos becomes a lot easier to
process
and it looks pleasing to the eye and so
that's what the grid will do for us
it'll allow us to organize things that
don't necessarily feel
as ordered as they want to be so i want
to move this out of the way
okay so i have an idea here
i think there's an opportunity here
shoot
okay what i'm going to do is i'm going
to take this text first
i want to make it a part of this group
there's no reason why it needs to be in
a separate group
all right now
generally speaking when we look at type
and if i were to ask you to read these
two
pieces of information the left side or
the right side
and at least in america here or
english-speaking countries
you're going to say that probably this
one's easier to read than this group
and why is that because when our eye is
scanning the page
it's able to find this corner point and
say el disitsky
wolfgang vinegar alvin lipstick
whereas this one our eye has to work a
lot harder let me get the brush here it
has to work a lot harder
brushes where are you
yeah it has to work a lot harder to find
each and every one of these points
and after a while if you're reading a
lot it becomes very fatiguing
and that's why generally speaking
paragraphs are set like this
on a straight line so it's easier for
you to find edges and to read the type
now having said that there's still ways
to make this work right
now if i were to take these two pieces
of information
and to interlace them
there's a relationship that's created
here now this looks really hard to read
and the reason why it's really hard to
read is probably this would be better if
there's
upper lower case it's just upper
lowercase is going to be a lot easier to
read
because if you look at this watch i'll
show you
we'll take alvin copy that actually i
have a better example
okay the example is this
and everybody that's driven on the
freeway knows what i'm talking about or
will know in a second i'm going to make
this bold
okay when you're driving down the
freeway and you have a split second
to figure out if you're on the correct
ramp north or south
and this is why there's a lot of
accidents like i can't tell i just can't
tell because almost
all these letters are the same and
here's why it's because we recognize the
shapes
before we can read the letters right
so if we were to bring this over and
we're to try to do this
in upper lower case
you're going to start to see this and
it's still a very very similar shape
so if we go further if we just reduce it
down to this
and this it's very now
very difficult to mistake north from
south because they have very different
properties
and what i mean is this if we were to
take a pen and block this out
i'm gonna block it out right now
i'm gonna do this crudely okay if you
were just driving
down the street and you had a split
second to make a decision you're going
to know north from south because they
have very different forms
as opposed to these right this is a
little bit better than this
because if you were to drive down the
street it would look like this to you
i think this is why they're people who
are just jumping on the on or off ramp
really fast because they just realize
they're in the wrong lane
this is where uh design really does
matter because design can kill
or at least bad design can kill
right you guys see the difference there
and then if i were to do this
it'd be very similar to this i could
block this out
block this mark any questions
yes we do so we got a couple coming up
we'll keep them up so we got kang
and then we've got brian butler coming
up so kang will i meet you
and go ahead and ask your question hey
so when you're moving your type around
on some of those layouts were you
thinking of just the relation in space
or were you kind of
planning to use a grid afterwards oh
okay good question
um i've been designing for some time now
that
a lot of the grid is kind of pre-baked
into my brain
but for a lot of you guys that are
starting out i would strongly suggest
that you use a grid
to help teach you about proportion
relationship and repetition
and i'm moving them around based on many
years
over 20 years of laying out type that i
kind of now
instinctively know where to put stuff
okay now in the beginning of my career
and my journey into typography
i was a slave to the grid the grid ruled
my life and for good reason because it
made things make sense
uh so we can talk about the grid in a
little bit uh did i answer your question
king
was that king was it something else
yup that was king okay cool uh okay was
there another question
no yep we have one from brian butler
here let me
mute him okay brian are you on
yep can you hear me no brian we can hear
you loud and clear man
all right uh so if the primary goal of a
piece is to communicate
in a logical manner if we need a focal
point um
then for like this example should
resonates consistently be the thing that
we design
um so people would notice it first yeah
very good question man
very good question okay uh and the the
answer i'm going to give you
it may make you more frustrated and
happy
okay now you could say uh
that resonate should be as the mass head
of a magazine
this is like some kind of art journal
right should always be
the focal point like here right
but in in terms of like how we can
interpret this information if you're a
long time subscriber to resonate as
a as an art journal you may care more
about the contents
so like who are the artists are going to
feature this week or this month
and then that may become more important
or you're a collector and you're you
want to make sure
that you're getting the february or
january february issue
then that may be the thing that you pull
up and highlight and
for typography and what we're trying to
do in the in this course and these
exercises is to really start to say
this is important to me i'm going to
find a creative way to bring this to the
top
and it's not always should it always be
resonate
but i'm sure if you were becoming the
creative director of the magazine
they would probably frown upon you for
moving their masthead around so much
it would probably be bad form because
people need to see that and say
yep that's the magazine that i love
that's the one i want to buy
so you would confuse people but for the
sake of this exercise
pull anything out try it and see what
works as long as you can find a reason
why
in your mind at least it is important to
pull it out
so that's how i cut it right in the
middle
so mostly yes but not always okay
any other questions got a good one from
youtube here from
key web concepts so they're asking when
you talk about looking at layouts
like a blueprint or a floor plan uh what
do you mean
oh okay
all right um
let me think about uh okay mark just let
me know about that one
uh remind me because i'm gonna find a
layout where it's very clear what's
happening
and then i'll talk about it okay
all right about the whole floor plan uh
okay
all right um all right so we were here
we're talking about upper lower case and
legibility
and you know legibility is really really
important until we start to get into
experimental layouts and then you can
start to play around with it
because you're going to see that once
you learn how to control type and make
it
interesting that you can start to like
really push the boundaries of legibility
and still
make it readable to people okay
all right so i'm going to take this
chunk here and then just move it out of
the way
move over here okay so getting back to
this i i still think that there's an
opportunity here to lace this together
and i want to show you how to make it
work
so first of all these letters because
they're all caps
it starts to blend together in here and
i want to introduce you some ideas
things that you can try out on your own
okay
so what we can do is we can try to
increase the leading which is
on the mac option down arrow right
so i'm increasing both theoretically the
same
and then we can try to lace it one way
or the other and see if we can create
something interesting
i i think i'm i'm battling the fact that
it's hard to read to begin with
but we're gonna we're not gonna give up
yet so i think command shift l will
justify it both on the left
so i can take this now and try and move
it to the left here
and create more options for you guys to
look at
and hopefully this starts to um
open up your mind as to what you can
what you can do
in this layout too i would suggest that
um who is this
james try to go eight point okay so i'm
gonna go eight point
oh it was already small okay eight point
now let's say we were only allowed to
use all caps
how do we create separation between
these two groups right yeah we could do
like this which is how
a lot of people are doing it but there's
another way we can do it
to create separation between these two
groups if i were to hit option
and the right arrow on my keyboard i can
open up the tracking
and increase it to a point and if i just
keep doing that where's my
type here i think it's here if i did say
400
no that's not enough let's say 750
to really open it up now you can see
like oh there's
no mistaking that this is one group and
this is a different group but they're
kind of related because of the proximity
to each other
right so this is where i want you guys
to play
with your type to see if you can create
something that's more interesting
looking
while still working with the parameters
of
the information you're given
okay now i may decide
you know features is
usually it's the opposite of the way
that you have this type set
usually features would be all caps and
then arm and hoffman would be
upper lower case okay
anyways i could probably increase the
spacing between features in this
just as to visually separate it from
that group and now what i would do is
then take this
and move it over so it lined up with
this
so now you get you guys get the feeling
of this and how this is starting to feel
a little different
so you can't adjust you can't change the
point size or the weight
for each layout but you can change the
leading and the tracking which
create a lot of different options for
you more than you thought
okay if i were to take this and decrease
you'll see that
this becomes a lot denser on the page so
if i were to zoom out
versus opening up the leading
it would feel more airy and light
okay and the last thing i need to do is
to figure out how to make this work with
this
so again i'm going to switch this to
justified left or flush left
and see what else i can do here
it's not feeling totally cohesive and
we'd have to really work on this to make
it
work here but i i kind of wanted to
demonstrate with james's work like
other options things that you can try
and find success in
all right okay
um mark how are we doing on time are we
okay
we're about an hour in but we do have a
question and then you want to move on to
the next
design right ask a question so this one
is from
beartron go ahead hi how's it going
hello um so i was just wondering you
know
when we're jumping into the design
program we're trying to
align all the elements to these
different grids yeah
um and uh i was experimenting with like
the golden ratio
like seven columns and like 12 columns
all these different grids
how would you go about picking the grid
for a project
uh that that fits fits the content
does that make sense yeah i good
question
uh i don't think okay there's a lot to
be made about grids and i think
in some cases people ignore them and
some people worship them and i don't
think either is totally right
i think it's usually somewhere in
between now i'm going to show you
how to deal with this grid thing here
let me unlock this layer
let me delete this i actually created
something here
all right i'm gonna copy it over here
okay i don't think grids are conceptual
so tying that into giving it more
meaning that it is and we've seen people
friends of ours actually
do golden section golden ratio grids on
top of everything
and it's actually you're just making
stuff up because it doesn't even line up
it's like forcing a design that you like
into
following a grid system that doesn't
even exist in the original
you guys want to make them all right all
right so
i'm gonna show you grid right now so
this is a fibonacci sequence and the
fibonacci sequence is fantastic as a
is a has a grid that's very dynamic and
i want to show you how to do that
let me make this black
i'll make a blue you guys can see that
right okay
now i want to repeat this across and the
easiest way to repeat is to grab this
and then just
go like this and hit that and then hit
command d
it just duplicates it hopefully i've
done this right so that
it's correct like it's not uh
misaligned there we go all right so the
fibonacci sequences uh you take
uh two numbers and then you add it and
that equals the second number
or the third number in the sequence so
it looks something like this if i were
to have
my type tool here and it would go like
one
sorry this is not in a place where you
can see it
okay you guys know fibonacci right so
it's one
and then and these are the two numbers
you start out with
okay my tracking is out of control here
back to zero okay so you add up those
two numbers and it'll equal
two you add up one and two or equals
three and then two and three equals five
three and five equals eight and eight
and five
equals thirteen and thirteen and eight
equals twenty one
and that's your fibonacci sequence okay
now this
number there's some very special things
about this number sequence that was
discovered and so what we can do is we
can use that so i'm going to take all
these things
i'm going to move it down so i'm going
to take two units
so there's one one and i'm gonna move it
here
right so one one and then i'm gonna do
two so
let me hit this so you can see a little
bit better
and then three
one two three four five
one two three four five six seven eight
okay that's as far as i can go because
i'm gonna run out of space so if you
look at this
ratio of blue blocks here you'll see
that it's actually very dynamic
so 1 1 2 3 5 8 right
and we can leave the rest alone and it's
going to make sense in a little bit
not just yet so if i scale this up
holding down shift oops i need to drop
the anchor point right here hold down
shift
and make it fit on this page
okay if i were doing this like it
mattered like i got paid for this i
would spend a little bit more time
working on this than now
and then i'm going to bring on my guides
and hit command r to bring the rulers
out
and i'm going to snap it to that point
can you guys see the guideline right
there i can go and change this color
here
i like a less obnoxious like really
brilliant blue glide because
it's overpowering sometimes but in order
for you guys to see it
and also did it do it
yeah and then i'm gonna do line so you
can see it very clearly now
okay you see that guide so that's one
one right
so i'm gonna do it again snap it to this
and just keep going
i'm sure somebody knows a faster way of
doing this i'm not that person
today okay so if i grab all these things
now
i'm going to rotate this 90 degrees
i lost a piece let me group this
okay so i'm going to rotate this now i
could start this this is kind of like
the
the decision that you have to make as a
designer as to where this grid wants to
start
and it's just something to help you not
something to enslave you okay
let's say like i like where this starts
here so now i'm going to pull grid lines
down
here everybody's following me so far
and when i start using this grid you'll
start to see like wow
that's that's really how you use it so
i'm going to flip it using the mirroring
tool which is
keyboard shortcut o and holding that
option as i click on this it'll flip it
upside down
right i'm going to flip it vertically
oops
sorry i went the other way
okay now i can also pull this grid
so it could start here so it repeats
that direction or i could do it like
repeating here but i think i'm gonna try
it here all right
everybody see the grid now i'm going to
put this somewhere else
get off my page all right now what i'm
going to do
is i'm going to add bounding boxes
or grid lines for the page itself
okay there we are so there's your grid
this is a fibonacci grid
arbitrarily decided on the horizontal
axis here and you can see that
now if i were to place typography in
these boxes and use this to govern
how i'm going to do a layout i'm going
to show you okay so i'm going to switch
my color now
back to black
all right i got black ink so i wanted to
draw a box so
the rule of using the grid is this is
that the first thing that you put on a
page is arbitrary
it's the only thing that's arbitrary at
that point so
why is it snapping to it okay i'm gonna
put something down right here
okay that's the first thing that's it
now you have to make decisions based on
that one thing that you put on the page
so if i say like i want something to
relate to that
i may want to create something here
and i want to create something
down here
okay so this is how you use the grid
system so that you can create
dynamically proportionate things that
kind of feel related to each other
and as soon as i add or change one
element on here
it impacts the layout the feeling of the
layout and if it feels off balance then
this first thing that was arbitrary
needs to move and this is the push and
pull of typography and design
you put down that one dot now you kind
of have to move things around to make it
work within that
uh so this will also teach you things
like this i'm going to show you
something
let me move this out of the way let me
just delete that
you could take this sucker and you could
put it over here
so i'm going to hide this right now you
can see like this will be related to
this
this is related to that this is not a
terribly interesting layout
and this is to remind you just because
you use a grid doesn't mean it's good
it's just a starting point for us to
work
okay now let's get back to that one
question that was
asked by people watching this live on
youtube like
what did i mean by floor plan okay and
this is what i mean
imagine like this is the layout of your
house okay we're looking from a top-down
point of view for like from a bird's-eye
view down onto your thing
and if you were to have like a dresser a
nightstand and a bed or something like
that like how would you lay it out
uh and if you're really trying to to to
make it interesting
you would try to kind of use the entire
space
so there's a flow and a movement you
wouldn't necessarily just put
the bed in this corner the dresser in
that corner unfortunately this is how a
lot of
american households are laid out and
then this over here it just would not
make for a very interesting room
there'd just be a lot of space in the
middle and not much else but if we were
to look at say a living room or
something
where you have a stand for the for the
tv
some couches you start to lay it out and
you would start to kind of configure
other furniture
shoot
in a way that activates a space so
somebody walks into your home like wow
that's really cool
love the layout and they're seeing
things and interior designers know this
also this this works like if you were
designing a grid pattern for building
for example
this and you see this a lot actually in
modern architecture okay
this isn't exactly line imagine now
you're looking at the facade of a
building
instead of just having let me delete all
this
let's say that you're looking at the
facade of a building
it's like a office park somewhere
right and that's how a building looks
and you're going to see a door here
if i can get that tool right right
there there's your office building with
retail space on the ground floor
this is why i tell you guys that
typography and learning to design with
type opens the door to designing
everything and massimo benelli was
famous for saying if you can design one
thing you can design everything
and this is what he's referring to okay
once you
understand proportion scale balance all
that kind of stuff so that's a building
that's how most buildings look
not very interesting to me at all now
look what happens
when i delete some of these things for
all of these things
i guess i should have just done it all
at once and you actually created
a more interesting pattern for windows
for the sake of speed here
that the building had more interesting
patterns
of color or windows or something it
becomes a lot more interesting to look
at
just imagine everything snapped to that
grid and then you you walked up on this
building and you'll see this now in
modern architecture
where buildings don't follow that same
kind of repetition that there's a
breaking up
of that grid line
okay i hope that answered i probably
confused more people than i helped
right now apologize in advance guys
all right let's get back to this thing
now i'm not going to be able to critique
everybody so i'm going to kind of push
through
some of this here where did you discuss
that layout
i actually like what's happening here uh
this is from
yoshino kumar kumar guy yoshino kumar
guy
that uh it's using one point size
and uh i i think
they're using either grays or tints or
shades
shoot let's see what this looks like
where's my properties panel
okay so the opacity is 40 and this is
totally within the boundaries
to create almost like a different weight
of font
by changing the transparency or the
opacity of
this type of bold it almost feels like
it's you're getting an extra
weight in there okay
there's some things that are problematic
here i think you're double spacing
and double spacing depending on
the letters before and after i think the
characteristics in a space
change so you may want to find a
different way to separate this
and here's one way you could do it you
could just do an underscore to separate
the names
that's just one way and it actually adds
a little kind of visual element
something that christina was using with
dashes or minus symbols
you can use divider lines
if you want and there's a lot more that
you can do here
okay okay that doesn't look so good
what if i just delete that and i did
something else
you don't always have to use spaces to
separate things you can use
transparency so if this were 40
and you alternated every other name that
could work
so there's a lot of options here and if
anything if you're watching this
either participate participating part of
this class or just watching live
just try things to kind of see what
works
to break it that should be your
intention let me try and see if i can
break it and
if i don't allow myself to use um
within working within a lot of
constraints what else can i do to make
this layout work
how do i separate information so now
when you put in the space back in
it's even easier to read
okay that's i think that's all i wanted
to say about this i mean i like that
they're
they're using the bolt type face and a
much bigger point size than we've seen
and i think that's pretty cool uh i
think this layout
would be improved a little bit if we
just didn't push everything to the
corner
so the top part being pushed to the
corner is cool i think we just need to
find a way to bring this back in
and maybe then the layout works again
again i would encourage you to probably
oh i see one one kind of temporary a
little bit of a problem here
you've decreased the tracking so much so
that the letters start to touch together
that's called the ligature i guess in a
way
and this is problematic here you see
this little triangle
now if you want to do that there is a
way to make that work
what i would encourage you to do is i'm
going to delete all this stuff
this is just an example here is to try
this
and and this does work and i've done
this before and people get all crazy on
me like nah
it's not good design okay sure if you
say so
okay if you have transparency like this
try to even
get it to even be more overlapping
because then it looks more intentional
versus just having a sliver so it's one
of those things where you don't want to
be kind of aligned
or kind of off set you want to be really
offset or
really off alignment and that's one way
you can handle that
and i think if we were just to actually
delete letters here which we can do
because it still works like that
oops there
with less letters it's even easier to
read
okay so that's how you make that work so
before and after let's look at this
okay there that feels like a mistake an
oversight whereas this
uh it's hard to say like that's not
intentional
so just to be intentional with your
design okay
all right
okay this is the work of marianna monroy
and there's something here that's really
cool i just wanted to point out to
everybody
who's looking at the design i really
like how you handled this the resin
eight
kind of being to the power of eight and
a parenthesis and adding that to it
i think that's really clever and i like
to encourage other people to explore
breaking your type up differently from
layout to layout just to create a lot of
components to work with so that you can
really play
the rest of it is just pretty standard
but i just really like that part how you
handled that okay
we talked about that one already um
this is an interesting layout here from
uh from
yoon kyon and
i like the interlacing of the type
creating different levels of tints or
transparency to help break up the
information you can see it creates the
nice little rhythm there
they picked one central axis to work off
of and
okay no surprise here
you know what i'm going to do oh are
there two point sizes here
let's see that's 12 point
huh what point size is this
that seems to be off so you have one
that's not 12 points
i'm going to make a 10 point actually
i'm not i'm gonna make it eight point
i like what you what you did here this
is all caps it lines up with the journal
for graphic design
telling the reader this is connected but
this is black
so there's a strong focal point there
and this is
tracked out a lot more than this so it's
we're related
but we're different i like that well
done there
uh this person uh jung kyun has decided
that the january february is very
important to them
it probably isn't as important as
they're making it but that's their right
to decide
okay if that's the case what i would do
is make this black and not this
there's something that's a little bit
off for me in terms of like the
hierarchy
if this were like this
i'm assuming that that's the same grip
good okay if that were like this i think
it would be a stronger layout
so the blackness of this would draw me
here first
get me to to look at this and i'll look
at that as a third
and maybe move this around a little bit
not sure where to put this just yet is
this a good candidate to talk about
floor plan blueprints yeah i thought i
already did that but
um yeah i just like if we were to walk
into this building let's just say i'm
gonna draw a person right now okay i'm
gonna draw a person
and round off their shoulders a little
bit
and give him a head
getting high tech here guys super hyped
my guys all right
that's a person and i'll give this
person a nose
there that's a nose in case somebody has
the wrong idea
right and i'll give this person a red
shirt or something
so you can see them a little bit better
there there's your person
can you guys see that so i'm gonna group
this person together
now as a person i'm gonna scale this
person down
okay let's say they're walking into a
cool exhibit in a museum
and they're walking okay they're like oh
this is really cool they can check this
out they can walk around stuff
and they can walk over here and look at
this that's like some interesting table
display that you've got
to come back here and i'm gonna turn
them around like they look at this i'm
like wow
this is really cool so there's a way for
them to navigate around this thing
and you say you're probably thinking to
yourself chris what's this got to do
with typography
well your eye is not that different than
this person your eye is going to travel
around the design
and it goes from point to point looking
at things and there's science scientific
studies tracking people's eyes and how
they look at layouts
understanding the relationship with
these things and if you were to put
all of these things to the edges well
you can see now
there's not a lot of things for your eye
to do so it just goes to the edges
that goes over there goes here and then
it's done it doesn't seem as interesting
to us
and and that's kind of what we're trying
to do is to create something that's
legible
but yet draw somebody in to look at it
if you can't stop somebody
uh in terms of catching their attention
and looking at what it is that you're
doing
then all your beautiful type won't
matter at all so we have to create some
kind of visual interest to draw people
in
okay
okay this is from tony gibbs tony uh
here's one of your layouts here i think
again what's wrong too big right
total point default i like that you're
using light
i'll just make this 10 because i i don't
hate 10
12 is just so boring okay and
grouping this stuff is a little funky
let me ungroup that okay
typically when you do a layout like this
what i would recommend
that you do is to keep everything in one
paragraph group
and that way the leading will line up
things will line up better
i'm not quite sure if you're doing this
by hand but
it creates problems for you so i want
you to try this tony
if we were to take this and push it
really far out what happens
well we lose the connection between
these things and obviously that's
impossible to read
so what happens if we go the other way
what if we bring it close
okay that's that's a relationship but
maybe not one that we want
and then what happens if we interlace it
or weave it in
oh okay that creates a little bit more
kind of
visual tension that i think is good um
and
that's probably how we can make this
work
so that's a little bit more interesting
now there's this thing
like is this hanging too far off the
edge of this thing i don't know so what
we should do is we should try to bring
it in
but then i realize right now we have a
small problem
in that this is flush right and that's
flush left
so if we were to make it both flush left
it probably will work a lot
better i can't do that right now because
of the way this is laid out
so tony if you're going to continue
doing this with us what i would suggest
in the future
is to keep this in a paragraph grouping
and not breaking out
into individual lines be a lot easier
for you to work with okay all right
see we already talked about that i think
we're kind of done here
yeah i think i've talked about
everything on this page so let me save
this
okay
i think we went through this
and while you're doing that chris we
should remind everybody that's watching
so if you're
wondering you know how people submitted
their designs and how chris is
critiquing them these are again people
from our typography one class
so there are series of exercises there
and we're
critiquing week one's exercise we're
going to continue with the remaining
exercises so
if you're in the course just look out
for an email from me or
join the slack group for typography one
and then you'll see the request
there yeah we're doing this again next
week right and next week it's a little
bit more interesting because we're going
to open up the parameters a little bit
uh do you remember what the next week
this assignment is the parameters
mark i believe it's two point sizes
point sizes i mean it's a world of
opportunities now
anyways i'm going to get back into it
real quick i'm going to power through
this in the next
six or seven minutes i'm going to wrap
this up this is from johannes
yellen i think or jell-o okay um
johannes has done something kind of
interesting he's made
the paper itself a different color shade
of gray
and this will work on your computer but
when you go to print this thing out it's
going to be very problematic because
you're going to see lots of little dots
okay but on the computer it looks quite
beautiful it looks really nice
this is one of those things where i i
would encourage you to
johannes to really try more layouts more
configurations to do things that you
think are not going to work
and when they break find a way to make
them work because i'm seeing a little
bit too much of the same
right this looks like a kind of a nice
letterhead here with everything center
at the top and
and then you have these bits at the
bottom not a lot of relationship pulling
the eye
towards these two things and hopefully
if you're still confused about this
whole like floor plan
idea you know it's like there's an
exhibit on the north side of the
building and an exhibit on the south
side of the building
but not a lot for me to go from one to
the next
and my eye needs something okay and i
think
of your three layouts probably uh this
one is one of your more successful ones
unfortunately this has all been outlined
so i can't do a whole lot to it
let me check yeah it's all outlined
right now so
unless again you're using an exotic
version of helvetica not even necessary
for something like this
just use standard old helvetica and
i can then work with it
so the alignment is kind of tricky but
just maybe a simple adjustment like that
could make it
look really good so uh johannes is doing
a bunch of good things here
taking one access and then offsetting
this type a little bit
which was what we've been talking about
and creating
three dominant groups with like one
focal point i like it
successful okay moving on kento yoshida
kanto all right let's look at yours
a lot of really interesting things that
you're doing in here uh the ones on the
left and the right are your
most successful layouts to me and let's
talk about i'll start with the one on
the left first then
okay i i think i mentioned this earlier
about using
different devices to separate things and
i think it's quite interesting to be
able to use these
these diagonal lines these divider lines
slashes uh
and then to make them more opaque than
the remaining
artists i think that's kind of cool and
that's what your eye looks at so there's
a really nice rhythm there
i would have i think the layout would be
stronger if you just
saved this device this
this diagonal line just for the features
so i think
repeating them up here and then making
them uh
fade out with transparency is actually
not making it stronger
it's diminishing the power of this okay
i don't think you need this here
nor here resin eight
okay and then okay
so now that i've changed that this is
feeling a little out of place here
i believe we could probably just take
these two things
um it's a command what is it uh where's
my alignment tools
just align them like that and bring them
back in
and offset them like that we want to
simplify it right
so it might be cool to
take this and just move it down a little
bit so that there's more separation
it's not working for me just yet
it's a game of proportion and just
nudging things around
shoot there's too many things going on
here where are my layers
i need to lock that background okay good
so sometimes you have a long line like
this the journal for graphic design
and what's happening is it's cutting off
all this beautiful space around it so
in a case like that the journal
maybe you just hit return here and now
you kind of change the way that this
whole thing looks
because you're giving yourself a lot
more space to work with so sometimes
that works and sometimes the inverse
works where you take
this and you
i'm gonna do something a little wacky
right now guys it may make your eyes
hurt a little bit but let's see what
happens
now most people see the page as
a kind of two-dimensional thing but what
if you did something like this
where you continue to thought across the
page
and that could work too so the your eye
will follow this resonate the journal
for graphic design
now the one thing i don't like about
this
is that it cuts off the space right it's
creating a space
of a volume right here
and then it's creating a volume down
here which i don't like
it would be better if we could i'm
cheating here just to
demonstrate what i'm talking about i'm
going to scale this down right
it's already looking better just by just
by doing that
and if i were to open it up like this
so that at least there's space to flow
through
but you guys will find out soon enough
in this in these exercises that
using a smaller point size gives you so
much more real estate to work with
because you can't change the page of
dimensions but you can change the point
size
now as soon as i say that somebody's
going to do a three-point thing which
will be totally illegible so
just caution you six points is probably
the smallest you can make this
so i'm going to return this all back to
normal okay so i think that's a pretty
good layout and i like what you're doing
here
when you find one trick just use it
sparingly don't try to replicate it
everywhere
and in future weeks when we start to
open it up to more elements
i'll teach you how to use that one trick
and make it tied to other things without
overusing it
okay here's another one here
let me just look at this
okay pretty standard stuff and uh kento
i'm not sure if you're using the grid
uh it looks like you have a grid but
they
doesn't seem like you're obeying the
grid
not sure okay this is like what one two
three four eight column grid
oh you're using different grids for each
one interesting
okay all right
i think here again watch all i'm going
to do is make this smaller and you'll
see
you're late i'll just get better
i'm not even going to change anything
all right and i think your use of grays
or transparency is actually really good
here
because although there's a lot of
information on the page our eye will
just see the things of greatest contrast
so the area of greatest contrast is
right here
let me let me do this so you guys can
see that it's right here
so that really jumps out because it it's
got a sea of black around it and just a
little bit of white
so okay keep keep going down this path
can't i'm
looking forward to seeing what you come
up with next so
say this and close it
okay who's working says king king who we
know
king all right
okay so kang
[Music]
the risk of repeating myself quite a bit
here
you see you've come up with a really
you've come up with a really kind of
interesting typeset here
for the magazine the mass head and the
date why are there so many boxes here
what the heck okay
so i guess you're using those for
proportion and space but next time just
delete them
or turn them to guides or something and
there's a really easy keyboard shortcut
to turn things into guides which i'm
going to do
right now with you i'm going to select
these and just hit command 5
it'll make them into guides
so they won't be there anymore okay now
you notice why like before i turn my
guides into dots and not lines because
it's super annoying to look at all this
and so you can go back into your
preferences which is command k
go to guides and grids and change them
into dots
see now you can actually see your design
again when you do that okay i'm going to
hide the guides
which is command colon or semicolon all
right
i think you've come up with something
kind of nice here and then you're using
it again so
if you're going to submit three designs
let's go crazy here
and if you look at these two layouts
they're almost identical
there's not enough exploration and and
all i can say is the more you push the
more you try the more you fail
the more you're gonna see yourself grow
by leaps and bounds okay
so i would recommend that because if you
look at it yeah this is just that but
like this you see the layout's almost
the same so
the only difference here between these
two layouts really is taking the type
and pushing it on the edge
okay now if you do this on the edge here
uh try one where there's nothing else
it's just one thing
like everything is super simple but this
one thing that you put on the edge
okay yeah same same same way of breaking
this information you guys see that
all right let's try and break it up
let's see what else you can come up with
king i know you got it in you
okay we're down to the last two joshua
gilly here
and
okay um i think this layout is very nice
it's very simple also joshua is
doing this thing where he's changed the
paper color to like a
shade of gray and i think that creates
an interesting visual here
it works for screen again and when you
go to print this out it may not look so
good to you
and if you're not sure go ahead and hit
it on your laser printer and see what
happens okay
and other than that i'm just trying to
find like where this thing belongs it
feels a little bit out of place here
i think you made it centered uh to solve
the problem like i don't know what to do
with it
i think it would work just as fine if
you were to line it up with something
like that
rather than aligning with the page say
say to people this relates to this or
this relates to this piece of
information here and
be done with it now once i do that
you're going to realize
also very similar breakup of the
body text here so let's push it josh
okay nicely done i think you have good
sense
sensibility and an eye for design i just
want you to try more
especially because you're only
submitting three show me three radically
different things like one on the far
left
one on the far right and something wacky
in the middle
okay last but not least we have mojo
okay mojo is doing something uh really
wacky here so i applaud
you for trying this mo and that he's
taking
resonate and he's repeating it and using
transparencies to kind of create
this echoey blurry um light leaking kind
of thing
uh and he's doing it quite a bit right
maybe this is now
oh lots of copies okay here's what i'm
gonna say mo
take this idea and make it the superstar
and the hero and that's it
by repeating it three times you diminish
the power of what it is that you're
doing
if you just did this one trick and kept
everything else really super simple
i think it might make for something
interesting i quite like
this replication like it's really kind
of blurry
and weird looking if that were done for
say the mass head or something else
i think that could be cool and then make
everything else subservient to that
okay in this one see this is what i mean
like when i say go try stuff and break
it
um most definitely mo is trying stuff
and breaking it so now
mo's thing is going to be to try to pull
him back
and show some restraint so this is
good for the discussion of what we're
doing here today you guys because some
people have stayed
really tight in what they're going to
explore and some people like mo
are going bananas and i like that now
it's like moe has to lean towards the
middle a little bit
where everybody else has to lean a
little bit more towards the edges
i like that you repeated the type here
using type as pattern and texture
probably kind of tough to work with this
huh yeah
okay and then moe's kind of deleted some
of the type in here to
help make this more legible so i like
the the the texture and the repetition
again if this were just like one giant
block a copy instead of like trying to
do this super dynamic layout
maybe that pattern repetition would be
more successful for you
okay okay i think that's it for me
let me close this thanks everybody for
kind of joining us today to talk about
type and this is just week one of i
think seven weeks we'll be back next
week when we're allowed to use
two point sizes i think that's what mark
said so when you go to do this next week
when you try two point sizes
try two point sizes that are radically
different like a really small one and a
big one
and see what happens see if you can make
it work and then
bring them gradually closer together
okay and
if you're also curious when you're going
to critique the work for next week
ask yourself is there a clear focal
point do i understand the order in which
i'm supposed to look at things
is there just like one element of
surprise to break up the monotony of the
layout
that's all you need repetition and
contrast is the key and make sure you
have a lot of negative space and the
easiest way i know how to do that is
just
reduce the point size down and as we
progress
i'll probably get into the details a lot
more than today
and i think that's it for me mark i'm
gonna hit stop share here
i want to thank everybody for tuning in
and also for mark and
jonah for manning the remote broadcast
team here
i hope you guys learned something and
i'm going to say goodbye to everybody
right now okay
hey chris yes people are asking what are
those plugins uh the architecture plugin
people are asking all right you crazy
animals let me do it let me share that
let me go back in there
okay sorry about that i'm gonna find a
file here
and give me one second mark maybe you
can read comments
while i go and find a file that can open
up so they can see what the heck those
little secret plugins are
okay okay so for some of you that may
not be receiving the emails
there's a chance that you might have
opted out of the emails in teachable so
we'll try to get those
to you i think i see some people in the
youtube chat that
didn't get the request hopefully you
guys
found this useful again we're going to
be doing this um not exactly on a weekly
basis but we're going to go through all
seven weeks of the exercises so just
look out for the request and
again if you're not in the course we do
have the course available
it's um we've reduced the tuition due to
the situation right now but
for those who are enrolled we're
offering free critiques so
look out all right uh i can't find my
file right now but i'm going to show you
what the heck this is it's from a
company
called hotdoor and they make a plugin
called cad
tools i'll write it on the screen in a
second here okay so
those are you guys that are doing
architecture design and don't want to
use
autocad there's a company called hot
door and the tool
or the plugin is called cad tools let me
make that bigger
let's switch this back to helvetica all
right
and i will show you what it does okay so
i'm going to pull out all the
all this stuff now hide all this
okay where are my cat tools
okay so you see the the plugins here on
my my toolbox here i have all these red
dots that's what that is okay
so what you need to do is you need to go
into cad i think the
the document itself now i wasn't
prepared to talk about this but you can
see
all these things that you can adjust and
change
cad walls etc i need to go and see cad
documents here
where is it cad tools these are all the
plugins here
so i want to look at my documents
if you're not from here familiar with
cad it's computer associated drafting so
drafting yeah
oh mark i wasn't prepared to talk about
this i'll show you
to you really quickly i don't think if
they're going to dub i think people just
wondering what it is
and what it does yeah okay
so the cat dimensions all that stuff so
it is a tool to draw floor plans
buildings and all that kind of stuff and
if you were to drag something open like
this
uh let me switch this so you can see it
there's actually dimensions on this
thing
and if i were to go to cad dimensions
you can see it but if i need to
draw everything in scale like i'm
designing a bookshelf or something
and i want to cut something right so if
i go to
cad tracker where is it
there it is i can change the dimensions
of this
right here so let's say it's saying it's
5.75 inches because i've not set it up
correctly but let's just say it needed
to be
a four foot by eight foot thing right
so let's say that's four foot by eight
foot right now it's four
inches by eight inches but i can set up
the scale and then i can use this tool
right here which is their universal
dimensioning tool
i can drag it out and then i can drag it
out here
and this is what i use to communicate
with my general contractor
and as i keep drawing it'll make more
sense because i'm able to control
and have very precise drawings and be
able to adjust them
kind of on the fly like this and you can
do little call outs like this
here's a call out so so anybody familiar
with architecture will know what i'm
what i'm doing and it's set up like that
it's pretty cool and notice that the
numbers are changing automatically for
me
that's part of the program
and they have things to help you draw
walls and and it's pretty cool or even
to draw doors and intersections
and to do an offset this used to be more
interesting
like before um you have all these other
tools but i can offset something and
it's
you notice when it's offsetting it's
saying 0.64 inches 0.7
and that's consistent all the way around
so those things are kind of quite
important in order to be able to
keep keep things uh proportionate versus
uh
sometimes when you draw a box on another
box and you scale it up watch i'll show
you what i mean
if i take this box and i use
let me delete this
if i take this box and i use the scale
even though i'm scaling up
proportionately you'll notice something
here what's the difference here
well it's longer than it is tall so this
part
scales out and looks much bigger than
the top and bottom
so that's where the offset tool comes in
handy now illustrator has these tools
built in too but
that's what it is that's all no secret
design plug-ins guys it's just for
drafting
and that's it any last questions mark
i'm tired
well we have ten more no just kidding
all right thanks everybody
i'll let chris sign it off but thanks
for joining us submitting look out for
the next request for submissions
yeah thanks guys i know that could be
kind of dry to be studying that type but
for the people who do love this kind of
stuff i hope you learned something
i hope that my next week you guys try
and push the boundaries i'm
really excited and looking forward to it
and if your work wasn't critiqued this
week
please do not feel bad there were over
50 submissions and there's only so much
time that we have
one of the reasons why your work may not
have been picked is because you broke
the rules
and it was clear that you broke the
rules you used shapes and used lines and
all kinds of stuff
we don't want you to do that right now
there will be a time and place for you
to do that
don't do it right now and when you
submit your three layouts just submit
three
using the template if you don't use the
template and if you submit more than
three
i'm not gonna look at it i'm just gonna
tell you right now all right until next
time guys
um be well take care of yourself